>> Bret: JOE BIDEN’S SON
HUNTER IS EMERGING AS AN ISSUE
IN THE PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
LEARNING NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT
ABOUT A SENATE REPUBLICAN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE YOUNGER
BIDEN.
CHIEF CONGRESSIONAL
CORRESPONDENT MIKE EMANUEL HAS
THE DETAILS.
>> THE 87 PAGE REPORT SAYS IN
2152 SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS, GEORGE KENT AND AMOS
HODGKIN, RAISE CONCERNS TO
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN’S
OFFICE ON EVEN WITH BIDEN
PERSONALLY ABOUT THEIR
PERCEPTION OF A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST REGARDING HUNTER
BIDEN’S ROLE ON BREE’S
MOTHERBOARD.
"DESPITE THE EFFORTS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS, THEIR CONCERNS.
WHILE FALLING ON DEAF EARS."
WARNING OF THE RISK OF
UNDERMINING U.S. POLICY IN
UKRAINE "OFFICIALS WITHIN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IGNORE THE
GLARING WARNING SIGNS WHEN THE
VICE PRESIDENT SON JOINED THE
BOARD OF A COMPANY OWNED BY A
CORRUPT UKRAINIAN OLIGARCH."
SENATE REPUBLICAN GERMAN
RON JOHNSON AND CHUCK GRASSLEY
LETTER REPORT.
TREASURY RECORDS SHOW POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AMONG AND
BETWEEN HUNTER BIDEN, HIS
FAMILY, HIS ASSOCIATES AND
FOREIGN NATIONALS.
A KEY SENATE REPUBLICAN CALLS
THE FINDINGS EXTREMELY
TROUBLING.
>> THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF DONE, A
LOT OF INTERVIEWS, WANT TO SEE.
IT’S VERY SERIOUS.
>> A SPOKESMAN FOR THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN SAYS IT’S ALL ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
"AN ATTACK FOUNDED ON THE LONG
DISPROVEN HARD-CORE RIGHT-WING
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT HINGES ON
SENATOR JOHNSON HIMSELF BEING
CORRUPT AND THAT THE SENATOR IS
NOW SMOOTHLY STATED HE IS
ATTEMPTING TO EXPLOIT TO BAIL
OUT DONALD TRUMP’S REELECTION
CAMPAIGN."
THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER BLASTED
IT.
>> RON JOHNSON SHOULD REIMBURSE
TAXPAYERS WITH THE MONEY THEY
WASTED.
THE JOHNSON REPORT SHOULD BE
RELEGATED TO THE DUSTBIN OF
HISTORY.
>> SENATOR TOM COTTON SAYS THERE
IS NO REASON TO BELIEVE THE
PRACTICES WOULD CHANGE IF
JOE BIDEN IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> FOR DECADES, HUNTER BIDEN AND
JOE BIDEN’S BROTHER HAVE BEEN
COASTING OFF HIS PUBLIC OFFICE
EARNING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
CHINESE FIRMS AND UKRAINIAN
OLIGARCHS.
>> THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SAYS THE
REPORT IS FURTHER EVIDENCE IF
JOE BIDEN WINS, CHINA AND MANY